The model file is 160 GB. The graphics
card has eight, and it still answers at
half a token a second on a card that
costs $20 used. That works because of
one detail in how this tool is built.
The model never fully exists in memory.
One layer loads, runs, gets thrown away,
and the next one comes off the drive.
So, here's the whole video. What OLM
actually does, the one job where it is
the only tool that works, and then the
three places where the trick stops
working. The model is Qwen 3 next, 80
billion parameters. Anwar Sher Pedinov
shipped it in September 2025 out of a
hackathon in Astana, Kazakhstan. He had
8 GB of video memory, 16 GB of RAM, a
pile of customer conversations he could
not send to the cloud, and no inference
engine that would load the model he
wanted to use. The project is on GitHub,
2,700 stars, MIT licensed. The table in
the readme is 80 billion parameters, 160
GB of weight, 50,000 tokens of context,
7 and 1/2 GB of video memory, 180 GB of
disk. Hold that next to a standard local
AI setup for a second. An 8 billion
parameter model at 4-bit in Llama.cpp is
4.9 GB. It loads into VRAM in one shot
and runs at 64 tokens a second. Qwen 3
next is 20 times larger than that.
Llama.cpp does not have a plan B for
models that do not fit. The file is too
big, the loader refuses, and you get a
wall. OLM ignores the wall. So, the
question stops being does the model fit
and becomes how does anything run at
all? OLM is a Python library built on
Hugging Face Transformers and PyTorch.
It loads transformer layers off your SSD
one at a time, runs each one on the GPU,
and throws it away before loading the
next. The model never fully exists in
memory. The attention cache goes to the
drive as well, at full 16-bit precision,
written out as attention runs and read
back when it is needed. Big MLP
projection matrices get chunked into
passes small enough to fit. Flash
attention keeps the full attention
matrix from ever materializing. The
result is that peak video memory stays
under 7 and 1/2 GB, no matter how large
the model is. That is OLM, and it is
where the tooling gets interesting
because you can see the design in one
strange row in that readme table. The 20
billion parameter GPT- is model runs
slower than the 80 billion parameter
Qwen 3 next. GPT- is loads all its
experts onto the GPU. Qwen 3 next is a
mixture of experts model, and OLM only
streams the experts a given token
actually routes to. The other experts do
not make the trip. Larger model, fewer
weights moving per token. Sparsity is
doing the same thing here that it does
in Llama.cpp, just over a different
bottleneck. Now, if you have actually
tried this, you have probably already
run into the number, half a token a
second, maybe one. And before you file a
bug report, here's what that number is.
The RTX 3060 Ti reads its own VRAM at
448 GB a second. A fast PCIe 4 NVMe
drive reads at about five. Ratio of
roughly 90. Every token has to walk the
active layers of the model off wherever
they live. So, whatever ratio your
storage has, your tokens per second
inherits it. That 129 times gap against
Llama.cpp was never really about the
code. It is a memory bus against a disk
cable showing up as a number you can
watch on screen. You can watch it happen
in the utilization graph. During decode,
the GPU sits mostly idle waiting for the
drive to hand it the next layer. Someone
on the Hacker News thread asked the
obvious question. If you are
bottlenecked on SSD bandwidth, why even
use the GPU at that point? A CPU would
be just as fast. The author replied that
the GPU still does the arithmetic far
faster than a CPU once the layer
arrives, and that every tier you can
pull into the pipeline helps. The
bottleneck moved. It did not disappear.
The sharpest counter argument in that
thread came from someone with an M2 Max
and 64 GB of unified memory. Same model
class at 4-bit using MLX, 42 tokens a
second. Same idea, opposite conclusion.
Fit the model into fast memory and you
win by 80 times. That is the ceiling LLM
is bumping against and no flag will move
it. And this is where the tooling gets
awkward in a different way. LLM does not
give you a lot of knobs. The behavior
you want is mostly the default. You
point it at a hugging face model, you
get streaming layer offload, flash
attention, chunked projections, and a
cache on disk.
The configuration surface is small
because the design choices are already
made, which is useful to understand
because it means when something is slow,
it is not a misconfiguration. It is the
bus. There is a second catch underneath
that one. If your SSD is slow, the
numbers get worse faster than you
expect. A PCIe 3 drive at 3 GB a second
instead of 5 cuts tokens per second by
another 40%. A SATA SSD is another three
to four times slower than that. The
README numbers assume a fast NVMe drive.
If yours is not, the gap widens and the
context fight is separate. Qwen 3 next
ships with 131,000 tokens of context.
The attention cache at full 16-bit
precision grows with every token you
generate. At 50,000 tokens of context on
an 8 billion parameter model, the cache
alone is 52 GB. That cache lives on the
drive. A fast NVMe can handle it. An SSD
with heavy existing right load or one
nearing the end of its write endurance
is a different situation. The author was
asked directly how badly this shortens
drive life. His reply, "Good question.
Need to research this one." That answer
has not been updated. A paper from
August 2025 made the broader argument.
The title does the work. SSD offloading
for mixture of experts weights
considered harmful and energy
efficiency. Pulling weights off a drive
burns more jewels than the cheap
hardware saves you in dollars. That is a
real number and it belongs in the
decision. So, that is the speed half.
The context fight is worth finishing.
Llama CPP on 8 GB of VRAM with an 8
billion parameter model at 4-bit hits a
ceiling around 32,000 tokens. Two
independent write-ups this spring reach
the same number. Push to 64,000 and it
probably crashes. OLM on that same 8 GB
runs the same model at 100,000 tokens.
Cash on disk, 6.6 GB of VRAM, 69 GB of
disk. There is a shape of job where the
speed comparison stops working because
one side does not finish at all. One
enormous document, full precision, 8 GB
of video memory, no cloud because the
document cannot leave the building. A
contract, a regulatory filing, a patient
history, a year of log files. Read the
whole thing in one local pass. The
author says so himself. This is not a
chat engine. It is an execution path for
large context offline passes. One
question left and it decides whether any
of this was worth doing. Is the 16-bit
copy still the model that ran the
benchmark? Almost every local model you
have ever run was quantized. 4-bit takes
a weight stored at 16 bits and rounds it
down to four. 16 possible values instead
of 65,000. You give up some accuracy and
the file gets four times smaller. OLM
does not do that. It runs 16-bit weights
and keeps the cash at full precision on
purpose because rounding is exactly the
thing it is trying to avoid. Which means
the model answering your questions is
the model that scored the benchmark, not
the compressed copy. That is the one
place OLM is not making a trade. The
commit count is the last number worth
looking at and it is the one I did not
expect. Llama CPP had five separate
tagged builds in a single 48-hour
window. The most recent one landed a few
hours before the script was finished.
OLM has had exactly one commit in all of
2026. One line in the project file
pinning a library version. The last
commit that changed how anything behaves
was November 29th, 2025. The roadmap the
author posted at launch. 100,000 token
context on 12 GB. A better cache
algorithm for mixture of experts models.
None of it shipped. 2,700 stars and the
work stopped. The idea is more
interesting than the throughput and
sooner or later somebody will implement
it properly in C++. So, set the bar
where it belongs. Half a token a second
is far too slow for an agent grinding
through a codebase unattended. It is
fine for reading a 50,000 token filing
and getting an answer by morning. Here's
how I would actually decide. If you want
to talk to a model, install Llama CPP.
Quantize to 4-bit, cap your context at
32,000
tokens on 8 GB of VRAM and stop reading
benchmark tables. If the model does not
fit, still Llama CPP. Try first, then
let memory mapping page from an NVMe
drive and make peace with one to two
tokens a second. If you need 100,000
tokens at full precision on 8 GB and you
can wait, OLM is currently the only
thing that does it. That group is small.
It is also real. And until llama.cpp
puts the attention cache on disk
properly, that group is the entire
reason this project exists. The thing
worth keeping is not the setup
instructions. For 2 years, the rule was
that VRAM is a wall. The model fits or
it does not and the only fix is a bigger
card or a smaller model. OLM turned that
wall into a door. A slow door, when you
have to walk through it half a token a
second, but a door. 80 billion
parameters, 8 GB, answers in real time.
Go run it, then tell me your tokens per
second and your drive speed. Those two
numbers together are the whole story.
See you in the next one.